normalerweise hat so viel aufmerksamkeit
zu geben aber ich hatte irgendwie das
gefühl wird das bedürfnis darüber heute
einfach mal kurz zu reden ach so und
leute bleibt bis zum ende dran weil am
ende werde ich nochmal alles mögliche
sagen bezüglich der neuen klamotten die
morgen und 1500 shop kommen werden also
ich wetter preise sagen und alles
mögliche also wenn ihr euch dafür
interessiert dann auf jeden fall noch
bis zum ende dran bleiben ich fange
jetzt mal von vorne an und zwar gestern
blog hochgeladen und war abends dann
halt im bett und hat mir die kommentare
unter dem blog durchgelesen und
normalerweise die wenigen kommentaren
täglich kommen also man gibt ja immer
schon mehr aufmerksamkeit als man in die
netten kommentare gibt den kommentaren
unter diesem video bahn halt nur so
standard hält sachen als irgendwelche
beleidigungen von wegen ich hatte keine
muskel und keine ahnung was ignoriert
man halt einfach aber das land auf einen
kommentar in einer zuschauerin meinte
luca hast du schon das video gesehen die
wahrheit über konkrete sie außerdem noch
da nachdem dieses video geschaut hat
wird vor den negativen eindruck von mir
hat mich auf die art hat und so
unglaublich halt schon ein bisschen ja
ich sag mal aufgelegt weil ich nicht
wusste dass ein anderer youtuber möchte
über mich verbreitet da für mich meine
zuschauer nicht vermögen natürlich muss
ich dazu etwa ganz kurz sagen das war
ein kommentar den ich dazu bekommen habe
also das waren jetzt nicht radikal wie
vorhin schon gesagt man fokussiert sich
als menschheit er auf den halbzeit auf
die ganze liebe auf jeden fall habe ich
dann halt noch an dem abend nach dir
gesucht noch gefunden habe die ersten
zehn sekunden angeschaut und habe gesagt
okay lukas sie den linken kopierte denen
ein ablaufplan reinmacht dass morgen ein
video hier ist gerade 14 08 und wollte
mir diese zeit mit euch zusammen
anschauen und die argumente wie gebracht
werden einfach nicht gegen argumentieren
und überhaupt keine hält auch gut gegen
diese person starten oder so sondern
einfach nur sagen wie ich der ganzen
sache gegenüber stehe wollte dahingehend
auch ein bisschen besser verteidigen
weil die auch wollen von mir ist und er
für mich auch ein negatives passiert
wenn ich halt auf dieses video
draufgehen steht doch dieses video wurde
vom nutzer entfernt das tut uns leid
dass die userin und das video wurde halt
von einem mädel hochgeladen hat halt
diese video heute ihr
bei einem laufenden band ich kann euch
nur soviel seine der drei sekunden
geschaut habe davon und dann habe ich
mir gesagt gedacht jetzt kann abend du
bist jetzt einfach morgen live an und
ich mach doch ehrlich gesagt wäre welten
dass ich so eine plattform geben auf
einem kanal ich habe gedacht wenn sich
computer von mir durch dieses video
beantworten lassen und sich dazu drängen
lassen sag ich mal einen negativen
eindruck von mir zu haben
abonnieren dann musste video ja
irgendwie kraft sein ich kann nur soviel
sagen dass ich von dem video 30 bis 60
sekunden geschaut habe das video hier
die war ein gewagter die und das team um
der treppe nicht die welt über die ich
war beim ich die welt über der in
bottrop im movie park und hatte dort
eine autogrammstunde die eigentlich zwei
stunden gehen sollte mit einer
viertelstunde pause um costa funk uns
klar zu kommen denn endlich haben mag ja
und ich am längsten autogramm
unterschrieben und das letztendlich
sieben bis acht stunden und die haut
auftragen die video die die youtube er
in den ersten 30 sekunden klar gemacht
hat war einfach dass die youtuber im
echten leben nicht so sind wie in videos
und das hätte ich eigentlich auch ohne
dieses video sagen können also jetzt mal
wirklich auch minimum runtergebrochen
youtuber sind nie im echten leben
ruinieren video weil wenn ich du wär die
welt meine hand der mario raid video
oder wie mario kart video dann wechsel
längst knapp natürlich bin ich im echten
leben ein bisschen ruhiger alle die mich
bei nichols über der in bottrop
getroffen haben oder auch bei der city
von content ihnen die wissen glaube ich
dass ich eigentlich immer versucht einen
recht zu machen dass ich eigentlich
versuche immer freundlich zu sein und
auch beim x6 über den daten macht sich
ja noch nicht an einen tisch und wir
haben auch darauf geachtet dass quasi
soll ein bisschen erlebnis ist das nicht
so ist so hier kommt an und die kripo
gehen wieder sondern mit allen möglichen
gerede wir haben alle irgendwie wirklich
zum beispielsweise irgendwie jeden
umarmt er in die normung wollte haben
gegenseitig unsere bilder geboren wir
haben teil
leute mit meinen machen das braucht da
noch gereckt und gesungen und keine
achtung passt und ich glaube also ich
habe auch so viele videos bei instagram
und twitter gewinnen wohl einfach nicht
wie man körperlich dich zu treffen mega
cool und so ich will jetzt überhaupt
nicht arrogant oder eingebildet
rüberkommen bei euch aber ich will
einfach nicht ein mich jetzt für etwas
rechtfertigen was wofür ich mich dann
rechtfertigen muss zu beginn schon
gesagt habe ich das video von der
personen über das die ganze zeit rede
nur 30 sekunden angestiegen glaube ich
irgendwie weg 7 minuten und das geht
doch nicht nur bei mich doch überall
blamieren diesen 30 sekunden um zu
schauen ob halo und sich darüber morgen
ein video zu machen hab ich mir die
kommentare unter dem video angeschaut da
meinten einige leute das ist unseren
will gegen was mir bei dem über der
gegeben wurde und warten die zuschauer
in so ein riesiges bild gemacht das war
größer als das war irgendwie ein meter
fünfzig mal 80 zentimeter groß das war
ein riesiges bild dafür klein ich weiß
nicht was das a und das waren sie knöpfe
oder so kleine pickel auf jeden fall
sehr aufwändig gestaltete fans quasi und
sieben personen präzisiert die mir das
gemacht hat
ich weiß dass sie zusammen foto gemacht
haben und ich habe auch dieses bild an
meinem manager gegeben und meinte hey
pakt auf jeden fall nach hinten so in
den backstage-bereich weil alle werden
geschenke liegen gerade bei mir zu hause
bei meiner familie in bitterfeld und ich
habe ja auch schon mehr werden mein
videothek gesagt hat sich demnächst
einen instagram leipzig machen wollen
oder vielleicht sogar einem blog die
ganze sache noch auspacken werde und ich
werde jetzt auch bei demnächst diese
ganze wanda forderte gar nicht wählen
können auf jeden fall möchte ich diese
komplette wand weil voll ist mit fällen
hart und auch die decke einfach das
komplette zimmer so ein konkreter
youtube zimmer komplett egal da gar
nichts damit zu tun ich habe wie gesagt
jetzt richtig auf der video ein gewalt
einer weit entfernt wurde ein anderer
sämtliche 30 uhr angeschaut habe und ich
glaube dem video nur drei minuten um
mich oder so ich möchte nur dieses wir
jetzt gerade machen
um diesen allgemeinen über haye zu
sprechen möchte youtube das video
gemacht hat nicht vorwerfen dass ihnen
abgrundtiefer aker von mir ist oder so
aber ich versuche halt immer leute wenn
ich die treppe bei dem fenster oder für
die so schön wie möglich versuchen wir
alle zu machen versteht dann bitte auch
dass ich nur ein mensch bin und nach
sieben stunden gegeben dass ich dann
nicht mehr auf jedem foto hier
eigentlich
ich komme einfach mal direkt auf den
punkt und war ich vor fünf jahren mit
youtube angefangen weil ich unglaublich
in minecraft gespielt habe und habe dann
die ersten drei jahre gemeinsam video
hochgeladen ich nach köln gezogen und
hatte ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr so viel
am hut und hab dann halt mehr andere
gängige sachen hochgeladen wie
beispielsweise gold simi later clever
bord radiator irgendwelche dummen
website game und jetzt derzeit ist es
halt so dass mein studium so ein
bisschen riecht dem ende zuneigt ich
schreibe dann meine bachelorarbeit muss
in anderthalb monaten abgeben und mache
dementsprechend derzeit der seit juni
traten aber das war nicht ohne kampf
machte mich jetzt mit freunden da habe
ich mir gedacht
die ganzen sachen die wir machen können
ich eigentlich noch blocken weil ich
wollte ich schon mal ein bisschen blogs
austesten wie auch ganz so ist für mich
und das kommt jetzt doch mega gut bei
euch an das ist einfach ein bisschen
meine entwicklung auf youtube und es
gibt immer leute die wir im ganzen hält
entgegen bringen weil natürlich haben
mich leute früher in minecraft abonniert
und die feiern jetzt vielleicht immer
noch mein körper ist aber okay dann auch
andere gaming waffen oder nur noch wo
hauptsächlich blog die sache natürlich
jeder hat mich verändert oder du bist
blöd und so waren alle aber leute ich
überhaupt sind von diesem videos einfach
nicht so viel her möchte ich mal ganz
kurzen kommentar zeigen die ich letztens
in seinem blog bekommen habe es
interessiert mich nicht was du in deinem
leben macht und geht mich auch nicht an
aber bitte stell nicht jedem scheitern
ist mittlerweile unter den rtl niveau
angekommen also wenn er noch mehr geld
braucht ruft die reine job team einfach
der ingenieur oder sonstiges nerv und
nicht mit deinem gesunde erstmal sind in
den ganzen text becker 15 16
rechtschreib und grammatikfehler drin
aber ja das ist halt einfach ein
typischer september erhältlich
natürlich direkt auf alles eingehen und
können sagen ey was versucht den job ich
studiere gerade und werde auch in einem
halben jahr normalen noch auf sieben und
rtl niveau mein gott du hast den rtl
niveau angekommen geschrieben und
seitdem arbeitet er mit solchen
kommentaren überhaupt nicht aber wenn
beispielsweise jemand schreibt er hugo
techniker die meinung von ihr bekommen
nachdem ich das video geschaut habe
denke ich mir einfach nur da urteilt
eine person über mich die mich überhaupt
nicht kennt das hat mich einfach eine
andere sache die mir vor ein paar tagen
auf facebook aufgefallen ist die zwar
nichts mit mir zu tun aber mit einem
sehr guten freund von mir kennt
vielleicht an die ecke hadidi mit dem
wir es unter anderem namen verraten wo
ich auch ein tor gemacht habe und der dj
und das auch bei studio 1 70 gefahren
und studieren 70 ist ja auch mein
netzwerk und die post ab und ihrer
facebook seite youtube videos von den
create an wir haben die tage auch ein
video von ag geborsten
im garten entdeckt aufgenommen hat
durchfall kann da kommentare darunter
wie beispielsweise der neue david guetta
das mischpult es aus und bin keine
stecker drin bis auf das stromkabel und
das display sowie die knöpfe leuchten
nicht mal oder auch ohne kabel kommt das
gut an und bei solchen kommentaren denke
ich mir einfach nur hey leute ihr
absolut keine ahnung das essen all in
one controller der funktioniert ohne
jegliche sachen steckten usb stick rein
und netzstecker unter ding läuft das
leuchten vom display und von den knopf
was man einfach nicht gesehen weil er
die sonne tag hält drauf geschrieben hat
selbst die musste da teilweise so gucken
und ich verstehe einfach nicht wie bei
solchen sachen eingegangen oder dem
facebook ist wieder da einfach ruhig
bleiben konnte er den leuten dann
sachlich erklärt es war doch mal hier
und hier sieht das ding noch hier und
hier bewege ich die knöpfe ich denke
also es gibt leute die suchen immer
irgendwo was wo sie ein irgendwie fertig
machen können ich will diesen ganzen
heer jetzt natürlich nicht auf das video
beziehen was da gestern für ein radio
nicht hochgeladen wurde ich meine das
video von youtube hochgeladen ich glaube
ich ihnen die tausend abonnenten hatte
das video ist gerade mal 800 auf berufe
unter meinen widerstand nur ein
kommentar bezüglich des videos aber
nicht beschäftigt
der dollar vor allem den leuten
negativen eindruck von mir immer wieder
sagen ja ich denke mir nicht scheißegal
ich bin wirklich mensch muss ich offen
zugeben was andere leute über mich
denken und wenn ich wieder zuschauer von
mir einen schlechten eindruck von mir
haben nur weil eine andere
personen die mich nicht mehr wirklich
kennt irgendwas verbreitet was
vielleicht nicht mal wirklich stimmt ich
kann das nicht welche stellung sie das
video entfernt hat vielleicht dass die
jetzt noch eine andere meinung hat mich
auf jeden fall heute so gefühl da müsste
ich mal über das ganze thema reden und
ich wollte einfach nur sagen wenn ihr
mich trifft dann wisst ihr glaube ich
ich bin so bei den fans wir haben
teilweise rat nachrichten für leute
aufgenommen wo wir dann einfach noch
gesungen haben wir haben leute mehr
autogramme gegeben hatte eigentlich
wollten oder haben leute gesagt ich
brauche noch drei autogrammkarte für
meine freunde oder wir und du kriegst
nicht reinkriegt zu ihnen ich bin
zwischendurch nach draußen zu den leuten
gegangen als schlange die nicht mehr
reingekommen sind weil zu voll war und
alle glücklich habe ich alles getan in
meiner macht steht und es auch immer
wenn ich treffe um euch irgendwie
glücklich zu machen genau das gleiche
auch in bezug auf meine videos also die
letzten tage kam ja ein paar blocks
royale auch mit drin war und jana macht
nicht mal youtube aber sie hat trotzdem
mails nachrichten bekommen und leuten
die der schwere zeiten durchleben wo die
eltern möchten weise gerade vor der
trennung stehen oder wo sie streit mit
ihren eltern haben oder irgendwie sowas
oder irgendwie gemobbt werden oder sowas
und wir haben da wegs nachrichten
bekommen und so laut jada die wirklich
nicht wie youtube hat der nachrichten
bekommen von wegen immer wenn ich die
blogschau oder so haben wir einfach
lächeln bewertungen für solche momente
machen wir einfach video ich möchte
jetzt nicht das ganze video hier zum
mega emotional wird und ich versuche es
doch wirklich auf den punkt zu kommen
weil ich bin in der raw datei gerade bei
43 minuten ich möchte euch einfach nur
sagen was nicht unterkriegen
zum beispiel ich hab früher mit youtube
angefangen ich habe noch die
überstellung nach dem schnee kommt ja
auch jeder gerettet und das ist ja noch
neu für mich hätten und dabei facebook
gibt leute die hätten weil er irgendwann
geht nichts falsch gemacht hat obwohl er
nichts falsch gemacht hat macht einfach
euer scheiß ding und einfach auf die
leute die etwas anderes sagen ich weiß
einfach dass ich meine community habe
die lubu soll ich so dumm klingen aber
ist halt nun mal meine community und ich
möchte einfach dass ihr wisst dass ich
alles versuche um euch irgendwie zu
machen zu bringen oder wenig kräfte
alles cool und eine ahnung was also ich
wollte einfach nur sagen scheiß doch
haye versucht einfach mal selber im
alltag also ein bisschen mehr liebe
entgegenzubringen ich weiß dass ich
davon zu gegen andere youtuber stecker
oder ich weiß nicht ob unser streit mit
meinen eltern haben keine ahnung aber
jeder art streit man kann nicht einfach
sagen es sind jetzt nicht der böse
zueinander wer wird alles ein streitwert
welche therapie einfach nicht aber wir
könnten alle man mit ihm mehr darauf
achten
zumindest halt auch im internet mit dem
freundlich miteinander umzuhängen nicht
habe einfach mal auf los gelabert blogs
wo ich immer so drei vier stunden im
schnitt gaben alles und ich wollte heute
einfach weil wir das ganze thema reden
und jetzt kommt endlich ganz kurzen
lukas auf und zwar ihr vielleicht
wirklich dass und jetzt hat er gehört
habe morgen um 15 uhr laut meine neue
sommerkollektion würde es eigentlich gar
nicht so wirklich eine sommerkollektion
ist weil nur zwei t shirts dabei sind es
läuft auf jeden fall fünf neue sachen
und ich wie viele sachen einfach mal
also sie haben das ja wahrscheinlich
schon auf verschiedenen bildern gewähren
die sich die preise zusammensetzen werde
ich übrigens am ende nochmal erklären
ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal die
produkte diese hier wird er nicht mal
den job kommen ja schon sehr lange welt
auch in der kappe drin ist überall - und
hier vorne ist das pad strauch mit luke
ruhe und das ganze so eine wandfarbe die
kirche zu 26 euro 99 geben dann gibt's
hier noch ein lieferstopp also könnte
man in kalten sommertagen anziehen oder
wir wieder einen 3d print genommen so
ein bisschen auslaufen das bluetooth
sehr hochwertig aber merklich zurück
unter dem motto print noch drauf der
stoff von ende der hochwertige jedoch
von jeder große bedruckt ist mein logo
mit der größe wieder und ihr rechner
über alle besser ein bisschen fransig
geschnitten einfach ein bisschen
regional dieser also das ist der lohn
bekommen wir 39 euro
zugegeben das auf jeden fall mein
lieblingssong von allen neuen produkten
damit auch dieses shirt gegeben von
claas shirt auch in zombies dann erst
mal wieder drauf das wird für 29 99
geben weil wir ein sehr sehr dicken
stoff gewählt haben also der stoff wie
glaube ich 320 gramm oder so ich glaube
das sieht man auf der kamera sogar recht
gut dass dieser stoff einfach sehr sehr
hochwertig es wird ja auch schon wenn
ihr euch an führte durch das kauft oder
so behaupten das ist bisher sehr geiler
straße den haben auch neue features und
zwar haben hier so kunstleder setzte
auch mit so einer hitze lungen drin
steht immer noch locker drauf auch
tiefer direkt drauf genäht und auch bei
dem longsleeve haben wir das ganze in
kunstleder in schwarz so hier draußen
noch ein rosa fahrendes mein shirt in
den luca schock kommen allerdings bei
mir gerade selber in der wechsel des 25
euro 99 angeboten ist auch ein bisschen
die kraftstoff geworden also ich meine
von t shirts also die man fühlte sich
nach der qualität und falscher mein ziel
die sachen noch ein bisschen
hochwertiger zu machen und als erstes
produkt haben wir noch ein paar bestände
der bettwäsche gefunden hat wegen 500
stück 59 99 angeboten weil ja jetzt hier
glaube ich jetzt bettwäsche produzieren
jetzt nicht am arsch der welt ist auch
qualitativ hochwertig also wenn die
bettwäsche möchte da gibt es auch noch
ein paar bestände zu kaufen
zusammengefasst also die fünf produkte
die kommt in einer zeit der
schwarz-roten fliegt dann dieses
thermoplastischer das rosafarbene tücher
dann die wettkämpfe noch die
restbestände der bettwäsche werden sich
jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder in den
kommentaren aufregen weil die teuren
treibe aber wirklich leute ich möchte
euch nicht wegen darf irgendwelche
produkte zu kaufen die leute die sachen
nicht limitieren die beispielsweise die
wieder und ihrer pingel gemacht hat also
ich will euch überhaupt nicht unter
druck setzen wenn ich die sachen feiert
dann würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr euch
gekauft ich habe diesmal auch wer die
nase verzichtet um die preise trotzdem
noch ein bisschen human zu halten
twitter youtube stecken ihr match mehr
arbeit hinsichtlich der gestaltung des
designs bei mir allerdings so dass sich
eher auf schiene design stehe also ich
versuche dann mehr bei der neuen
kollektion die wachen die hochwertigen
zu machen durch den dickeren stoff oder
durch kunstlieder patrick unten dran
oder keine ahnung hast also ja die paar
euros die neuen produkte teurer geworden
sind
die beispielsweise in der
winterkollektion
und in der tat darauf zurückzuführen
dass der bug qualitativ hochwertige
rohstoffe haben wir haben als team
gingen wieder an 3d köln wer mit
kunstleder plätze bei den thermodynamik
komplett neues design kreiert
der stoff ist auch viel dicker geworden
die band hat eigentlich normalen weltcup
event besten gleichzeitig vorher unter
verursacht mittel gegen die aus zwei
euro teurer als die hilfen brauche nur
bei der stoff wird auch ein bisschen
dicker in den neuen patch also wie
gesagt ich möchte ich überhaupt nicht
unter druck setzen wenn ihr die designs
nicht feiert in ordnung dann kaufte ihr
halt einfach nicht wenn ihr die ersten
im monat bedeutet wird jeden monat immer
noch versuchen die sachen werden jetzt
limitiert sein oder wie gesagt morgen 15
leute lounge ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr mal vorbeischaut und dieser stellte
das video beenden
ich wollte heute halt einfach mal über
das thema hält so ein bisschen reden und
euch halt am ende noch mal eben die
produkte zeigen jetzt morgen den schock
kommen werden ich will gar nicht mehr
lange bleiben weil es noch gerade
irgendwie 80 grad drin ich bin der oder
52 minuten